[Music]
welcome back everybody diabetes is a
very complicated and dangerous health
condition
it can even put someone more at risk
with covid so i spoke to southwest
medical to learn more about diabetes and
how they can help
we're educating the community on
diabetes because some people
obviously know what it is but they don't
know the basics of it so let's break it
down
let's do it all right so diabetes is a
serious chronic illness
affecting somewhere around 10 percent of
our population
but an interesting statistic that i read
recently uh the cdc is estimating that
one in three
children born today will develop
diabetes in their lifetime
wow in 20 to 30 years one third of our
population is going to have diabetes
so obviously it's a serious health
problem
and we need to be taking steps to
prevent it now
so diabetes is a disease where the body
is unable to properly regulate blood
sugar
so instead of the sugar going into the
cells where it can be used for fuel for
your body
it remains in the blood causing what we
call hyperglycemia or high blood sugar
so your blood is supposed to throw flow
through all of your arteries and veins
like water
through a pipe system and that pipe
system delivers all of your nutrients
all of your oxygen
everything that your body needs to all
of your cells so when your blood sugar
is really high
instead of the blood flowing through
those pipes like water
it's flowing like syrup and we always
hear about type 1 type 2 so what are the
different types of diabetes and the
comparisons between the two so type 1
diabetes is actually an
autoimmune disorder so it's where your
immune system
develops these antibodies we're not sure
why we really don't know
what triggers it but the body develops
these antibodies that go in and attack
the pancreas and make it
unable to produce insulin type 2
diabetes there's no autoimmune issue and
the pancreas usually still produces
plenty of insulin especially when you're
first diagnosed but the body can't use
the insulin effectively because the body
becomes resistant to the insulin
so it's a genetic disease usually
usually runs in families
but it's exacerbated by having ex as
body fat eating an unhealthy diet and
living a sedentary lifestyle
so that's why it's so important that
everyone go in and get regularly tested
see their doctor at least once a year
because a lot of times you don't know
that you have type 2 diabetes until you
get tested
and then there's a third type of
diabetes that is gestational diabetes
uh which only occurs in pregnant women
it usually goes away
once the woman delivers but it puts that
woman at higher risk of getting type 2
diabetes and also the child
at at higher risk of getting type 2
diabetes later in life
and what are the symptoms if people do
get symptoms
um the symptoms are going to the
bathroom a lot
your blood your body's trying to get rid
of that sugar any way it can and one of
the ways it does that is by making you
kind of pee it out
so patients will start urinating more
frequently they'll be really thirsty
because they're losing a lot of fluid
like i said they may feel very hungry or
just never satisfied with food or they
may crave sugar a lot
they may be extremely fatigued they'll
get blurred vision
and then another way people are
diagnosed is if they get these cuts and
bruises or if they're sick a lot and
they're just not healing
because like i said diabetes makes it
harder to treat infections
southwest medical associates has
locations across southern nevada just
call them at 702-877-5199
or visit s-m-a-l-v dot com we